now the duke and duchess of sussex have
signed a multi-year deal to produce
films
and series for netflix no less let's get
more on that with our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills so
we know what they're going to produce
drama rom-com something like that
so it sounds like they're going to be
making a whole range of different
types of tv programs and series we're
told it's going to include
scripted series docu-series
documentaries features
and even children's programming but yes
certainly it is fascinating because this
is the first big deal that the duke and
duchess of sussex have signed
since back in january they announced
that they wanted to step away
from royal duties they have been over in
america trying to settle into a new way
of life within the covid restrictions
still trying to do as much charity
work as they can but it's certainly
fascinating to know that this is the
first big deal that obviously groundwork
has been going on behind the scenes
to try and get this in place now we're
told that the projects
the programs they're going to make are
really going to focus on the issues that
resonate with them
so one of those big issues of course is
diversity so when it comes to both
on-screen talent
and talent behind the cameras they're
going to make sure that they have a real
diverse representation
of people we're told that already in the
making there
is a series to do with nature
and also animation series all about
inspiring
women now in terms of what the couple
have to say about this new
deal in a statement they said through
our work with burst communities
and their environments to shining a
light on people
and causes around the world our focus is
going to be on
creating content that informs but also
gives hope
they go on to say that as new parents
making inspirational family programming
is also important to us
as is powerful storytelling through a
truthful
and uh relatable lens now i suspect
there will be a few people
out there saying yes megan used to be an
actress in the past and yeah we know
that prince harry
has certainly been involved in his fair
share of uh documentaries when it comes
to being interviewed and things but i
suspect there will be people who'll be
wondering
how much experience they really have
when it comes to taking on a deal
like this but of course the obamas
they've already done the deal with
netflix we know that harry and megan are
good friends with them so i suspect
that's probably had something
to do with it but of course for netflix
as well they are a huge international
brand
and who would not want the guaranteed
audience that they're going to bring in
by signing this deal